if we could resolve all puzzles in
physics without recourse to a Multiverse
my inclination more like an aams razor
approach would be to take those ideas
most seriously first but if we
continually run into a brick wall in
trying to answer fundamental questions
in a single Universe framework and we
can answer those problems in a
Multiverse a multi-universe framework we
should at least allow that to be part of
our toolkit we should allow it to be
among the ideas that we take seriously
and pursue it mathematically and for
instance try to answer this measure
problem with that we are doing science
and so I think that to me is the most
rational and sensible way of thinking
about it